back in Washington Democrats say the
newest evidence in their impeachment
inquiry comes straight from the
president's own acting chief of staff
that's Mick Mulvaney who tried walking
back comments yesterday that the
president withheld nearly 400 million
dollars in military aid to Ukraine while
demanding that Ukraine investigate
Democrats Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill fourth Nancy quite the press
conference from mr. Mulvaney what's the
reaction
well Democrats seem Mulvaney's comments
as an admission of wrongdoing while
Republicans see them as a headache at
best even the president's own lawyers
we're told were blindsided by what he
said
Mulvaney is now insisting that this is
all the media's fault and that his words
were misconstrued things have just gone
from very very bad to much much worse
after rejecting the notion of a quid pro
quo for weeks the White House appeared
to suddenly switch gears and I have news
for everybody get over it there's going
to be political influence in foreign
policy acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney said the President did withhold
millions in military aid to extract a
promise from the Ukrainians like look
this is a corrupt place I want to send
them a bunch of money did he also
mentioned to me and past the the the the
corruption related to the DNC server
absolutely no question about that but
that's it that's why we held up the
money he's referring to a debunked
theory that Ukraine secretly helped
Hillary Clinton and that 2016 election
meddling actually originated in Ukraine
not Russia all roads lead to put
Mulvaney's comments directly undercut
what has been the Republican defense of
the president every single witness every
single fact has not supported any aid
pause or or hold up in foreign aid being
attached to any conditions
Mulvaney also suggested the president
wanted Ukraine to cooperate with a u.s.
investigation
but a senior Justice Department official
pushed back in a statement saying if the
White House was withholding aid in
regards to any investigation at the DOJ
that is news to us by nightfall
Mulvaney was walking back his comments
saying in a statement there was
absolutely no quid pro quo and that the
president never told him to withhold any
money over a server but impeachment
investigators were already focused on
his earlier admission New Jersey
Democrat Tom Malinowski Mick Mulvaney
basically confirmed to us the heart of
the matter here which is the Trump
administration held up at the
president's order vitally needed
security assistance to Ukraine for
political help from the Ukrainian
government Mulvaney did insist the aid
was not conditioned on an investigation
into the president's potential campaign
rival the money held up had absolutely
nothing to do with Biden there's no play
and that was the point I made to you but
it's worth noting that the President did
directly ask his Ukrainian counterpart
to investigate Biden in their July phone
call more fallout from this whole
controversy this morning we've now
learned that Energy Secretary Rick Perry
who is under scrutiny for his actions in
Ukraine has now told the president he
will resign from his post he is expected
to leave jail by the end of the year all
right Nancy thank you very much